brandon judd border patrol agent and
national border patrol council president
joins us now
do you think the administration is doing
anything to get ahead
of this caravan
busting through barricades in mexico
heading straight north
has nothing to do with what i think is
what i know i know this administration
is doing absolutely nothing to protect
the borders to protect our citizens what
you see right now is completely total
chaos what you saw when they busted
through those barricades that was
anything but peaceful and those
individuals are coming up to our country
and ultimately they're going to be
released into our country after they
violate our laws they're going to be
rewarded for violating our laws by this
administration
so can't
joe call the president of mexico and say
hey el presidente we got a little issue
down there in your country you know
you're our top trade partner let's work
this out because we can't have mass
chaos on the border when this caravan
arrives is not going to be good for you
it's not going to be good for me
so let's get some fix in quick
can you do that
absolutely i'm going i'm going on 25
years in the border patrol and i saw one
president that was willing to do
something like that that was president
trump and when he did that we saw
numbers drop exponentially if president
biden wanted to end this border security
crisis he could do it it's like a light
switch he could do it by putting the
requisite pressure on mexico he could do
it by re-implementing policies and by
the way jesse it doesn't cost the
taxpayer a penny if he does it by policy
we can in fact control the border with
the resources we have we don't need more
technology we don't need more manpower
we need policy which doesn't cost the
american taxpayer
he keeps patting himself on the back for
uniting these 30 nato allies to protect
the border of ukraine he can't get his
one ally
just to the south of us mexico to stop
this flow and protect our border it
doesn't make sense what would you do
right away first thing if you were in
charge with this caravan well the first
thing i would do is i would re-implement
the micro protection protocols but even
if he chose not to do that he could he
could operate with this within his
parameters stop the catch and release
hold people in our custody here in the
united states pending their deportation
or asylum proceedings if he did that
people would stop coming it's again it's
like a light switch
they will not give the car tells
thousands of dollars to be smuggled to
the united states if they know they're
going to go back the only people that
are benefiting from this are illegal
border crossers the drug smugglers and
the cartels they're generating billions
of dollars out of our policy it's policy
that is allowing these people to
generate the billions of dollars yeah
the american workers are losing money
with inflation while the cartels are
getting rich
what are the
border patrol agents telling you you
know when they whisper in your ear when
they see you after a long day of work
what are they saying how do they feel
defeated we all feel defeated we all
feel like this administration has waived
the right with the white flag of
surrender they've given everything over
to organized crime and when we put on
that uniform we want to go out and we
want to protect the american public but
we just don't feel like that's happening
right now we do it day in and day out
simply because we want some semblance of
control of the border we need an
administration that's going to step up
to the plate and do the right thing for
the american public all right brandon
judd
unbelievable situation down there
uh our hearts go out to you and keep up
the great work
thanks jesse hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else